kurze frage erinnern sie sich noch an
den sozialen wohnungsbau
ja das ist so circa 28 spd-vorsitzende
her was wir heute haben nennt sich
leider sozialer wohnungsbau überwiegend
in berlin startet bald das volksbegehren
deutsche wohnen & co enteignen
da sollen tatsächlich alle enteignet
werden den mehr als 3000 wohnungen
gehören
was sagt man dazu gerade
alles kommt wieder
kein zufall dass das in berlin
stattfindet gerade berlin war in den
letzten jahren in den letzten zehn
jahren so eine art eldorado für
immobilien spekulanten die haben da ohne
ende ehemalige sozialwohnungen gekauft
und dann wird meist lustig für die
mieter bisher zahlt sie pro monat 545
euro kaltmiete jetzt kommen 404 euro
obendrauf modernisierungs zuschlag alle
bewohner haben ein schreiben von der
hausverwaltung bekommen mit folgendem
hinweis leben heißt veränderung
ja viel sensibler kann man es nicht
machen dass mit diesen modernisierungen
ist übrigens die lieblings masche der
firma deutsche wohnen die ihren gewinn
2018 diese woche bekannt gegeben im
vergleich zum vorjahr um unfassbare 11
prozent gesteigert hat und der allein in
berlin 100 10.000 wohnungen gehören
allerdings führt der konzern sich gerade
ein bisschen missverstanden und gelobt
besserung
ganz wichtiger wert auch im umgang mit
unseren kunden ist respekt ist nicht
handelbar
markus alles erklärt was das unternehmen
besser machen bild wohnen wird smart und
mieter heißen ab jetzt kunden ja das
hilft natürlich enorm weiß nicht wie es
ihnen geht ich werde viel lieber als
kunde abgezockt muss ich sagen die
profitieren natürlich von der enormen
wohnungsnot in den ballungszentren die
wir gerade erleben vor allem in berlin
ja vor allem in berlin wo die mieten
stärker gestiegen sind als in jeder
anderen deutschen großstadt wo novia zum
beispiel deutschlands größter vermieter
hat im letzten jahr 1,1 milliarden euro
gewinn gemacht gewinnen das ist rekord
das ist eine zahl mit soviel nullen dass
selbst der vorstandsvorsitzende nicht
weiß wie viel er daran verdient erfolg
zahlt sich aus auch für den
vorstandsvorsitzenden rolf buch für die
höhe seines gehalts muss er in der
bilanz nachschauen
die tatsächliche verhütung ist 4,7
[Musik]
wir würden es spricht doch für ihn dass
danach gucken musste das sind 4,7
millionen also für den job hier für den
hier herzlich willkommen zur heute show
der besten sozialneid sendung
deutschlands ja enteignen ist trotzdem
quatsch enteignen ist quatsch vor allem
so enteignet der kauf dann stellen sie
sich vor das bankrotte berlin von denen
wohnungen für viel geld zurück diese in
vorjahren idiotischer weise für den
upload fertigt haben so ihre jetzt mal
ernsthaft werden dieses volksbegehren
erfolg hat wohin die berliner dann das
geld her und nebenbei aus dem
länderfinanzausgleich in diesem sinne
[ __ ] euch alle und grüße aus der
hauptstadt
größer ausfallen ja
junge junge im nachhinein im nachhinein
ist man immer schlauer und im nachhinein
hätte man echt mehr in immobilien
investieren sollen hallo ich bin reich
das wollt ihr auch sein
dann mach doch herzlich willkommen zu
meinem neuen schulungsvideos reicher
werden als gott mitte wo novia methode
so leute problem die spaten da in berlin
lassen sich ja immer neue sauereien
einfallen mietpreis bremse am
mietspiegel orientieren
macht aber nichts der neue schlüssel zum
glück heißt nebenkosten eines der
schönsten deutschen wörter
nebenkostenabrechnung oder wie meine
mieter sagen nebenkostenabrechnung
das zauberwort heißt insourcing
möglichst alles eigene tochterfirmen
erledigen lassen ja da hat er alle
mieter zwar das recht die rechnungen
einen zu sehen aber was bringt das wenn
wir uns die preise komplett ausdenken
der fensterputzer kriegt 900 euro pro
fenster der ist einfach sehr gut
beispiel in einem wohnobjekt in dresden
haben sich die kosten für den
winterdienst in nur einem jahr fährt 20
ich muss ganz kurz warten bis eine
erektion abklingt wer sagt denn dass es
im winterdienst nur im winter geben muss
ein blick doch noch kein schnee bei
nebenkosten wusste schon kreativ sein
auch wenn sich die meter hinterher im
fernsehen ausholen
hier hat wo novia sogar leistungen
abgerechnet die gar nicht erbracht
worden sein können
so will der hausmeister die
kellerfenster überprüft haben obwohl das
haus keine keller fans
und genau das hatte doch überprüft ob
neue kellerfenster dazu gekommen
ein hausmeister der cd zimmer in der
wohnung aber es wirklich noch drei sind
zimmer überprüft macht nur 700 euro
hier kommt wo wir entscheiden selber
auch wenn zb einen spielplatz einmal im
monat oder einmal am tag kontrollieren
ob darüber schreiben rechnungen und die
kinder sind sicher wichtig zur bank
neues konto eröffnen
das alte ist leider für reiche geben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja
wer möchte mich reicher werden
so haben sie vielleicht gelesen aktuelle
meldung die ratingagentur moody's droht
wenn es zu enteignung kommt würde
berlins kreditwürdigkeit heruntergestuft
worauf viele berliner gesagt haben was
berliner der kreditwürdigkeit
übrigens hält die firma blackrock
anteile sowohl an moody's als auch an
deutsche wohnen aber das ist sicher
zufall was oft hilft gegen wohnungsnot
ist bauen ja hat man jetzt rausgefunden
bauen insbesondere berlin muss viel mehr
bauen wir können ja mal gucken wie das
bis jetzt so vorangehen und scheiden
live ins berliner bauaufsichtsamt zu
matthias matschke
wie läuft so ein schöner zur frage herr
welke er ist läuft scheiße und die
gallus werdet schönzureden sämtliche
berlin klischees stimmen dieser warrants
der coma haufen dem wir hauptstadt
nennen kriegt ne backen und zwar egal
wer regiert er ahnung ob die hier was in
string quartet menschen pro forma dort
aber wenn denn funktioniert sonst
funktioniert irgendwie nicht gar nicht
so sagt dieses krank berlin der maske
da ist mir ist fast ein bisschen viel
berlin klischee muss ich jedes jahr
ziehen über 40.000 neuer bekloppte in
diese stadt warum hier ist nichts
vor allem beim wohnungsbau geht es nicht
schnell voran
30.000 neue wohnungen in dieser
legislatur war die zielmarke das muster
auf 25.000 korrigiert werden
jetzt kommt die folgen die rennen sollen
haben gesagt nach 25 runden schon mal
nicht im sozial meine behörde stellt
jetzt in ganz berlin so warnschilder auf
niemand hat die absicht irgendwann zu
bauen
völker der welt aus dieser stadt die
zahl der baugenehmigung ist mein letztes
jahr zurückgegangen es sind weniger ist
müssten mehr seien es sind aber weniger
aber warum er sich denn kinder ist
völlig egal hier spart der behörden
konfrontiert sind elano eigentlich sei
das baurecht einbau verhinderungs recht
sagen viele in der branche
das ist grotesk des empire state
building wurde wurde innerhalb von 15
monaten gebaut aber nicht von berlinern
dann ist alles fertig
und dort wollen wir nichts holen lassen
terminal 2 am berliner flughafen wird
wird jetzt doppelt so teuer überrascht
irgendwie watson nei spüre bei ihnen
einen gewissen fatalismus
ich spür seit jahren nicht mehr ich
warte nur noch auf die rente oder den
tod
je nachdem was zuerst kommt wichtig ist
nur eins diese stadt darf nie wieder und
ein großprojekt in angriff nehmen nie
wieder
das bundesinnenministerium will den
vorstoß für eine erneute
olympia-bewerbung berlins prüfen
der landessportbund berlin ist dafür
dass sich die stadt um die olympischen
spiele 2000 36 bewirkt cottbuser bitten
und herren
hans de schreibt über die heute show ihr
seid die richtigen links [ __ ]
besonders welke die stradivari unter den
arschgeigen bei euch smileys
freudentränen freudentränen
freudentränen freund rennkurs mit herz
vielen dank für ihr freundliches
feedback für ein exklusives geigensolo
von oliver welke
abonnieren sie den kanal